[Music]
can you believe you're at the Emmys
right now
yeah yeah I I don't believe in a nun's
then I do believe so has been such a
massive success we're getting a season
two how pumped are you guys to reunite
together on screen very excited I'm just
like jumping up with joy like actually
like I'm probably running around in my
sleep but I'm definitely am very excited
for season Q and hanging out with these
with these Butthead yeah for sure we're
getting to alright this is a very
important question guys what is the
ideal way that we can get justice for
barb there's a chance we could get barb
back I hope one thing that you guys
would like to see in season 2 of
stranger things what are you hoping for
cuz I want to see the return of you my
lovely lady ITC but I I'm not I don't
knowi back so it's very exciting if I am
back and if not it's very great season
you guys want to see for your character
I want Lucas to do more bad but not you
know what the word is right yeah like
last season everyone likes them but they
didn't because he's mean to 11 but
actually loved her in real life but um
yeah so yeah I want to Lucas be more bad
but I'm excited to see more dust in
one-liners
[Music]
you